conclusiones pueden sacarse de esta
semana teniendo en cuenta la situación
no solo los resultados sino además la
situación interna de Francia Bueno yo
creo que la de Francia es el ejemplo
claro de que una selección no sólo está
hecha de individualidades sino un buen
colectivo en este momento de está
teniendo esta dificultad de encontrar
una cohesión y una idea de juego que
logre un poco llenar ese vacío que deja
el mediocampo un medio campo que además
lo recordamos muy bien en el mundial
estuvo marcado por kanté y por Pogba un
equipo que sale a atacar de esa manera
necesita ese equilibrio y evidentemente
jugadores como camavinga y chomen Y si
bien pueden tener en el futuro unas
grandes actuaciones en este momento
están logrando o teniendo dificultades
para encontrar ese balance de cualquier
manera estamos hablando de que este es
un equipo que lleva 10 años con el mismo
entrenador y evidentemente los ciclos
empieza a tener a tener ese peso es
difícil de todas formas saber cuál va a
ser el resultado de un equipo de estas
individualidades en un Mundial Pero esto
es lo que creo que está pasando y lo que
se ha visto en esta liga de Naciones con
el equipo francés esta semana también
dejó reveses para equipos como
Inglaterra España Alemania podemos
vislumbrar ajustes a partir de lo que ha
sucedido esta semana sí aunque yo no
metería en la misma bolsa a España y a
Alemania que Inglaterra Yo creo que el
caso más grave es el de Inglaterra
tiene tres empates y dos derrotas en
esta liga de Naciones lo cual habla
también de una falta
digamos de una idea Clara por parte del
técnico South Gate Es evidente que
cuando la pelota no le llega kane y a
pesar de los intentos que hace foden y
algunos de los jugadores en el
mediocampo no logran ser claros a la
hora de atacar y esto genera
complicaciones Porque desde el banco no
se encuentra en soluciones ahora
Alemania sufrió la primera derrota en
esta era de flick por lo tanto no creo
que sea tan preocupante Pero lo que sí
empieza a ser preocupante es que cuando
encuentran rivales que le cierran muy
bien los espacios estos equipos tienen
dificultades para llegar eh al último
tercio de la cancha en el caso de España
hoy Tuvo una posesión de más del 70% en
esta fecha Tuvo una posición de más del
70% y no logró ser preciso pero yo creo
que hace parte de digamos de este
proceso que lleva Luis Enrique en aras
de mantenerse mantener un equipo que
gire siempre en torno a la pelota a
tener la posesión insisto cuando estos
equipos cierran los espacios va a ser
muy complicado creo que esos ajustes se
harán y que estos equipos van a ser
competitivos en la copa del mundo y ya
pasando la fechas FIFA Brasil hizo una
apuesta muy agresiva frente a ghana pero
quería preguntar es posible sustentable
mantener esta propuesta ya en un
ambiente mundialista es muy interesante
tomar que tú me decías hoy detrás de
cámaras cuando estábamos preparando los
temas que esto era casi que un 325 no
como cinco jugadores atacando pero lo
que también podemos ver Y cuando
analizamos las diferentes variables
tácticas que tiene el equipo eso es lo
interesante
es un equipo que puede atacar con cinco
jugadores son equipos que también podría
ser un 4-141 cuando pierde la pelota o
un 433 también cuando está atacando Y
eso es muy interesante qué es lo que
vimos que puede ser un equipo que juega
con vinicius Neymar como mediapunta
paqueta ayudándole a Neymar mucho en esa
fase defensiva y sobre todo por derecha
rafiña adelante y como referencia de
área está el jugador de la Premier
League Y entonces lo que encontramos es
un equipo muy balanceado yo creo que
esto es lo que vimos a lo largo de la
eliminatoria con este Brasil un fútbol
que le fue cuestionado en el sentido en
que no parecía ser ofensivo pero yo creo
que lo que está encontrando es ese
balance cuando encuentra equipos que lo
dejen ocupar mejor los espacios Así que
yo creo que este equipo de ti te sigue
demostrando esa fortaleza él no quería
ponerle mucha prisión a vinicius durante
las eliminatorias y por eso incluso
muchas veces los ojos fuera de la
convocatoria pero lo que estamos viendo
Es que todo esto que ha venido
trabajando a nivel sudamericano tite
empieza a dar resultados en otros
escenarios evidentemente gana fue
menos de lo que esperaba como un rival
para tener en cuenta Así que yo creo que
tite va a ser una muy buena presentación
en este mundial como lo hemos venido
planteando Muchísimas gracias Sara por